good morning founders welcome to startup
school 2019 I'm gonna go over four
things in this orientation I'm gonna
introduce you to the syrup school team
I'm gonna introduce you to your fellow
classmate / founders I'm gonna explain
how startup school works and then give
you a tour of the software the events
and the content that we're making for
you for the next ten weeks there are
five people that make up the startup
school team me and adore are YC partners
we will act as the hosts and we'll also
instruct some of the lectures Steven
Pham is the batch director he's in
charge of helping you guys with all the
logistics and answering your questions
and help you understand what's next and
just being super helpful and responsive
to whatever it is that you might need in
regards to what do I have to do for
start-up school we have Kyle he's built
all of the software and written all the
code that you guys would go be using for
the course and he'll probably be adding
new features as we go on based on your
feedback and then we have Ashman who's
going to be act as the person who's
going to represent your voice he's gonna
be analyzing the data looking at the
stuff that you submit to us and then
looking at all your feedback and even be
reaching out to many of you many of you
to get an understanding of like how a
startup school going are we sort of
meeting your needs and helping me and
adora adjust what is necessary to make
the course be so much better for you
guys and then we have an army of YC
alumni and then of course all the
partners who are giving lectures who's
going to be participating and helping us
out they'll be inside of the forums
they'll be at our live events and it's
going to be super awesome if you need
help this is the email start-up school
at Y Combinator calm that person is
probably going to be Steven that's
Manning that but he'll triage it
appropriately where I hope you will
ask for lots of help is from your fellow
classmates from the forums it is
actually a lot of how sort of YC works
people will constantly come to the YC
partners to get help they actually rely
on one another and it's through the
forms of where this is going to happen
where the community is built and it'll
feel really magical we've got a couple
of goals for the startup school team I'm
hoping that you can use us as an excuse
to work on your startup we have built
this 10-week sort of structure we've
built these set of lectures based on a
curriculum that we think works for all
different kinds of companies and we hope
that you will use us as a vehicle for
working on that passion project or idea
we want to improve how you think and
talk about your shirt up we want to help
you understand how investors think about
ideas and we want you to get a lot of
practice in on talking about your idea
in a concise and clear way and then for
companies that are already launched and
have users our revenue start school is
going to be an awesome place for you to
revisit first principles to look at how
you thought about the idea and try to
find oh we're there holes in your
thinking or where they're opportunities
in thought that can help you sort of
unlock growth or opportunities or even
completely rethink how your business
might work and then lastly we want to
build a global community of founders
something that's we think hasn't been
done before at this scale now for most
people who start Y Combinator and are
entered into the batch most of them have
this thought that they're in the wrong
place that they're too early that
they're too late or they have impostor
syndrome and I want you to know that you
are not alone that you are in the right
place
and that you're in good company there
are 28,000 founders who are
participating in start-up school and
another 25,000 people who are auditing
the class just to get updates and keep
up-to-date on sort of the lectures and
ideas that we're presenting one thing I
want to say is that more people are
going to be joining the class we've
actually moved the deadline because we
realized that hey since we you know
require 8 out of 10 group sessions or
weekly updates to consider that as
graduating from the course there's no
reason why we should cut off signups
until after the second week so the
deadline now is August 4th and
spectators expect me to try to get you
to join us founders over here and
working on your startup sooner than you
might think
you're ready now there are 21,000
startups that are registered for
start-up school and I want you to know
that there are so many different kind of
startups taking this class and that we
have actually designed a program that's
going to work hopefully for all of you
11,000 of you are full-time 8000 of you
are part-time and that means that we're
gonna work on helping you think about
your idea in a way that make you feel
confident about quitting that job or
figuring out what you can do when you
have only limited amounts of time to
work on your startup so that your most
productive on your startup we have 4,000
launched companies but we also have
5,000 companies that only have
prototypes 4000 who are just at the idea
stage and that means that we've got
content for all of you 5,000 of the
companies are actually teams and 16,000
companies are single founder companies
this is a record for start-up school
part of that has to do with the new
single founder matching program that
we've built into this year software but
I want you to know that we've got really
great resources for you there's 12,000
companies that have at least one
technical founder which means there's
9,000 companies that have no technical
founders and I want you to know that
that doesn't mean that you're hopeless
you have opportunities and we have
content and inspiration that will work
for you and then we have 4,000 companies
that have at least one female founder
and so you all will hopefully be able to
find and support one another I want you
to know that you might be skeptical why
how can an online class be able to
address all these different types of
companies needs and I want you to know
that this is basically what regular Y
Combinator looks like in an actual batch
we have groupings we have people who are
non-technical we have people who are
teams or just single founders we have
people who are just at the ID and
prototype stage and we mix them all
together every single batch and the
reason we're able to do that is because
companies are more alike than they are
different and that for all of them we
always have to revisit first principles
and that most of what we have to help
them with is storytelling of their
company which everyone can always use
help with for thinking about things from
first principles to figure out like what
are better ways of unlocking growth and
most importantly is we figure out how to
match them and group them up with other
people that are just like them or have
them be influenced by other people that
are ahead of them and our group sessions
are going to be designed to help you get
just that in an online way which we're
really excited about companies are in
over a hundred and forty countries these
are some of the cities that have the
most number of startups that are
participating in start-up school for
many of these we are organizing our own
live events but we also know lots of
other companies where people are
self-organizing lecture watching events
or their own sort of meetups and we
totally support you to do that because
one of the nice things about doing a
bonet in a community is that you're not
alone you get a chance to sort of vent
and that sort of help sustain you when
things are difficult and hard and so as
we said you are in good company and
you're in the right place this is just a
couple of the verticals that we have
doing YC 2400 companies working on bdb
solutions 1,400 doing artificial
intelligence startups 400 companies
working on blockchain ideas and one that
I really really love is that we have 97
companies working on moonshots really
really hard tech solutions which I'm
super excited to be a part of here is
how to graduate you only have to do two
things and we've made it really really
simple it's the reason why we have such
a high pass rate for start-up school you
have to submit eight out of ten weekly
updates these are really quick quick
briefs about your progress we have no
content restrictions basically you just
have to submit something ain't out of
the ten weeks show us that you're doing
something on your company and doing some
kind of self reflection and then you
have to participate in eight out of the
ten group video sessions and that's it
this is super easy and maintainable to
do and we don't ask that much extra time
of you we want you to spent as much time
working on your own startup as possible
so this is not going to be onerous one
thing to keep in mind is that you must
submit a weekly update to be able to
participate in a group session so if I
was going to choose one to skip I would
definitely not skip the weekly update
because that walk means you will
automatically probably not be able to do
a group session and so you don't want to
be in that bucket because that's going
to make it much more difficult for you
to graduate how do you get the fifteen
thousand dollar grant how do you become
eligible for that well you have to
graduate which means eight out of ten
weekly updates and the group sessions
and then at the end of the course you'll
apply to I see super simple application
is due September 25th that's or
Wednesday on the last week of the course
we'll actually spend some time talking
you through and giving some advice about
how to fill up that application and this
works out really nicely both for us and
for you it works out well for us because
we're reusing the same system that we
use to read through thousands of
applications and that's all it's a
two-for-one for you guys so not only you
applying for the $15,000 equity free
grant you're also applying for a chance
at one hundred and fifty thousand
dollars that we give to the YC Corp
companies I want you to make it very
very clear that nothing that you do in
start-up school and nothing that you
have submitted in the past and past
applications affects your future
possibility of getting into the next
batch and the reason that you should
believe us is that it would be
ridiculous for us to have permanently
rejected for example the founders of
Dropbox based on their home were out
homework helper application and thinking
that they would never be able to come up
with some other idea so again nothing
about the stuff that you do or
participate or submit during start-up
school means that it's going to affect
your future capabilities of getting into
YC I want you to know that we do not
think of it like that and I hope you do
not think so either so let's just remove
that myth now after submitting on
September 25th we will do interviews in
October and I want you to know that if
you get lucky enough to be also accepted
into the YC batch for the next time but
all you cared about was getting the
equity free grant you do not have to
take accept it into YC right the other
thing to keep in mind is applying for
the grant is totally optional and
applying to IC is also optional but in
order to get at the grant you have
- I see that just sort of makes things
efficient for us and I think it just
doubles your opportunity for something
wonderful to happen to you time
commitment so based on our basic
requirements those two things that we
want you to do it should take about two
to three hours a week and that means
taking about 15 minutes to write your
weekly update it should not take longer
than that you should not be writing a
long essay about your company we want
you to practice being concise as much as
possible that's going to help you
through all the different parts of you
talking about your startup either with
others or to your board or you to
employees etc we're going to generate
about a hour of video content every week
and then there's going to be 30 minutes
to 1 hours in a group session and then
probably another 15 to 30 minutes to
prep for that depending on how much
dedication you want to have for that in
regards to what you should block off
we recommend Thursdays at 8 p.m. your
local time for the group sessions this
is the time that we've found last year
most people were able to do group
sessions or were available so we picked
this time for everyone as a default if
you can't make Thursdays at 8 p.m. you
can switch that up and I'll talk about
that later on throughout the week this
is kind of the major things that comes
up that you should expect on Mondays we
open up the weekly updates for you to
start submitting them and then we also
do them what day ama inside of the
forum's we record the live lecture at an
office on Wednesday mornings and then
your weekly update is due by 4:00 p.m.
on Wednesday Pacific time if you don't
submit it by then you won't be able to
be matched up for a group session we
need to have that deadline give us
enough time for that
our algorithms to run and then the video
lectures release for those people that
didn't attend the live recording session
that's will be released on you
to Thursdays at noon and then we have
the group sessions that are scheduled
Thursday at 8 p.m. and then on Fridays
we do an AMA also in the forums here are
the important deadlines just to
re-emphasize them Wednesday is 4 p.m.
Wednesday at 6:30 p.m. this is when the
algorithm sort of locks the groups down
so you can't change your time or be
asked to be put into a different group
after this time period
Thursday at 12 p.m. we released a video
lectures on YouTube 8:00 p.m. local
times when group sessions start what's
in our software so again we have the
weekly updates in the group sessions but
we also have lectures the meetups the
directory the forums the library and the
deals as you can see there's only two
things that are required for you to use
in our software all the rest of stuff is
optional stuff but these are the 8
things I'm going to go over for the rest
of this presentation weekly updates we
started asking you Mondays at 12:00 a.m.
the update is about the progress that
you made in the previous week we do ask
you to tell us about your goals for the
upcoming week but for the most part
brass need to analyze the last week's
work so take about 15 minutes it should
not take longer than this if you're
getting stressed out about this you're
doing it wrong there do Wednesday's by 4
p.m. and you can find them under than my
updates tab here's some tips to help you
with your weekly update you got to be
honest if the number is zero in terms of
progress made on your key metric whether
it's revenue or engagement you need to
write down 0 don't change your metric to
something that is not as important ok if
you do that you will not help yourself
and you're not tricking us you want to
be concise again it shouldn't take that
much time you want to be really good at
the sizing and summarizing your
experience so that way you can learn
from it quickly later on if you are
before launch we're gonna ask you how
many weeks until you are able to launch
and some people think that's a
ridiculous thing because some people
believe that it's gonna take them months
and months or even a year to get to
launch and well we want you to
internalize starting right now is that
launch does not mean the polished thing
that you feel comfortable sharing with
the press and investors it is a thing
that you could finally put in front of
users and have them start using it so if
you're that stage then go ahead and and
launch and if you're before that stage
we actually think it should not take
more than one week or two for you to get
that ready and we'll talk about that and
week twos lecture 99% of you should be
tracking revenue so if you are launched
there's two different types of metrics
there's revenue metrics or engagement
metrics and almost all of you are in the
category of being like I'm eventually
making money sooner rather than later
and so you should be using those revenue
metrics the only companies that are
tracking engagement metrics are ones who
have to build a large audience before
they can start collecting money so
Facebook is a good example they had to
build a lot of engagement and users
before they able to turn on an
advertising platform so if you are not
in that category then you will not be
tracking or you should not be tracking
engagement metrics and then you should
always be talking to users so we
actually ask you how many users did you
talk to you and what did you learn from
them or what insights did you learn from
them whether you're launched or before
you are launched and that is because
that is the best way to make sure that
you're building and making something
people want which is our motto at Y
Combinator this is what that update form
looks like there's additional sussed
that is shown to you if you check off
that you are launched profile please
complete your profile keep the company
updated and add your co-founders if you
haven't already to your cup
the reasons you want to do this is
because it affects the matching
algorithm when you're assigned for
groups we sign you based on your
location we sign you based on your
vertical we sign you based on whether
you are a company team or a single
founder and so you want to make sure all
that is accurately filled out right now
I know a lot of you when you register
you just fill that you know dummy data
our filler information but you don't
want to have that before this first
group matching begins and then different
features available to you when you were
searching the directory so again you
want to make sure that these are filled
out accurately this is what it looks
like you click on your face and the
sidebar to access three these three tabs
group sessions so they start at Thursday
at 8 p.m. local time don't worry we will
send you emails with all the information
as we go through every single week so
it's not like you have to do all the
heavy lifting care just make sure that
you're accepting emails from startup
school at Y Combinator calm these group
sessions I've done over video using our
software so some tips if you have
multiple co-founders and you are located
in the same city try to share one video
connection that'll sort of make it a lot
smoother try to do them from a desktop
computer and then from a broadband Wi-Fi
connection I know not everyone is able
to do this but if that is something that
you are able to do that will give you
the best possible experience since it's
video chat remember that you have to
submit a weekly update to participate in
a group session so make sure you do that
on Monday Bob ideally when we send that
out but definitely by Wednesday at 4
p.m. you can request a different time
that 8:00 p.m. on Thursday you cannot
request a different day it's only on
Thursday if you pick a different time
you will match up with other companies
and a different time zone and probably
not close to you by proximity so that's
just something to keep in mind the
grouping algorithm is run at four
30 p.m. so 30 minutes after the lot the
updates are due for the week and then it
will send you on email let's say like
hey does this look good to you are you
going to be available for a group
session what do you talk about in a
group session every week you're gonna do
the same thing you're gonna intro
yourself you're gonna intro what the
company does we call this a one-liner YC
you're gonna share last week's progress
very quickly this should take no more
than 30 seconds to a minute
what were your biggest obstacles and
what are your goals for next week the
big goals then it just basically opened
up the discussion and then at the end
you're able to provide anonymous
feedback through the software of the
other companies one-liners and pitches
and so there's three questions that we
asked you to rate people long is do you
understand what the company's building
based on the one-liner are you excited
about the problem that they're working
on and that does this seem like the kind
of team that you would want to work with
and that way you're able to get feedback
from lots of different people about how
clear you are about your solution about
whether what you're working on excites
or entices other people and whether
you're giving off the kind of energy or
you're the kind of team that other
people can see as being exciting or
compatible and so one thing to keep in
mind is you don't get access to your
feedback
unless you provide feedback to others so
it's super valuable when we ran these
test group sessions people really loved
it and so please keep in keep that in
mind about the groups and matching group
sizes are between five and eight
companies if you did startup school last
year this is very very different last
year we did have like 20 companies that
you got matched up with and you you work
with them every single week the problem
with that format was that people sort of
trailed off over time and then the later
group sessions actually got worse over
which we did not want to replicate so we
did smaller group sizes we match you
based on all these different
characteristics automatically and then
if you're a single founder who's stated
in their profile that you're looking for
a co-founder all these other people in
those group sessions are other single
founders looking for co-founders and
then every week you'll match it up with
different companies and remember these
are companies that are submitting their
weekly update and so over the course of
the program you will get to meet with
between
50 to 80 startups have lots of different
practice gets lots of different feedback
from them build up a connection with
people that are close to you that are
working in your same vertical or making
the same amount of progress and what's
gonna be sort of awesome about this is
we think this will result in like as you
do the group sessions it's going to get
better and better over time so the last
group session will be one of your best
ones versus it being worse and worse
over time lectures okay we've got 20
lectures plan by the illustrious YC
partners we record those on Wednesdays
at 9:00 a.m. we do open it up to startup
school participants to attend in person
when we record those most of those are
in San Francisco
there's a little bit of a first-come
first-serve for that you can look out
for those emails a week before we filmed
those we release the video live to
everyone else in the public Thursdays at
12 p.m. we will also do some bonus
lectures and workshops all lectures will
be followed by a Q&A and then one thing
that we changed is made sure all
lectures are 20 minutes or less I think
that's sort of more appropriate for the
YouTube generation and we'll make sure
that we are focused on giving you in a
concise way an efficient way information
that is tactical that is practical and
something that you that you're going to
be able to use right away hopefully
these are the locations of the lectures
so July in August we're doing them at
that's why CSF office and then in
September we're taking circle on the
road and so that's why they're located
in other cities meetups
so one thing we did that's new this year
is that we're organizing events for
start school participants and cities in
all around the world to meet one another
and we're gonna have YC partners there
we're gonna have YC alum there and then
we're gonna do just like giant Q&A and
maybe have some discussions about the
lectures and just give you an
opportunity to like feel like you're not
alone and meet other people they're
gonna happen on evenings between 5 p.m.
and 8 p.m.
they'll usually be on Saturdays and you
should check the schedule you'll find
that under the events section on the
sidebar here are the list of cities
we're super excited about these will
probably add some more startup school
meetups after start school is over and
so that's gonna be like the wonderful
thing we'll have about this is that
we'll continue doing these live meetup
events if they end up being really
popular and then anyone who's done
startup school will have access to being
able to participate in them when
possible one thing I want to keep in
mind is I do not think that you should
spend a ton of money or time trying to
make it to one of these meetup events if
you're accepted we're going to try to
make sure that like it's meant for
locals and really I want you to spend as
much time working on your startup rather
than commuting so heads up on that
directory all right so this is a new
thing that we've built but the software
thanks to Kyle it helps you find other
companies you can filter by name
description the vertical and the
proximity to your city all companies
from your group session so whenever you
do a group session those five to eight
companies what we will do is make those
available inside of the directories so
you can easily find those and you don't
have to let sort of exchange contact
information after a group session and if
you're looking for a co-founder this is
where you'll be able to filter by other
co-founders who are also looking so this
will be super valuable to you especially
since there's sixteen thousand single
founders eight thousand of you are
self-proclaimed technical founders but
there's also a thousand that are not
technical so it's almost like there's
one for each one of you and hopefully
you will find one another
there's also twenty eight hundred female
single founders in their directory you
can't search by just females we decided
that might result in some other adverse
effects that might be unwanted but I
want you to know that there's gonna be a
lot of people in there looking to find
some kind of magic one thing I want you
to keep in mind is not to spam the
directory you will be banned from all YC
events if you're caught doing this
unfortunately we already had some people
abusing the system this is what the
directory feature looks like here's some
tips I want to give to you about what
you should expect from this co-founder
matching and searching system do not
expect that you're going to have a
co-founder by the end of the program I'm
not saying it's impossible but I
actually think that is not your
expectation what you should hopefully be
able to do is talk to a ton of other
people that are in similar
situations have the same shared risk
profile and hopefully just start
conversations start sharing favors and
seeing who are people that you might
want to like do a side project with or
work on a feature with or just help out
and then during that blossoming of that
small exchange of favors
you might start having the conversation
to say like hey I like to spend a lot of
time with this person I like making
stuff with them maybe we can start
entertaining the idea of being
co-founders so again during the course I
imagine that's probably not going to
happen so you should set your
expectations on just meeting talking
with people seeming helpful getting
inspiration getting support from one
another and then seeing where that might
carry you after the program the forums
so again it's usually the most
underutilized resource I've seen and
startup school but it is one of the most
valuable things that we have in the
actual YC program so I just want to
spend some time on this when you post to
the forums the only rule I really have
is make sure that it's a post that's
going to help the community don't have
posts that are purely selfish for
yourself don't just promote don't just
have odd discussions it should be
something that like the community would
benefit from even if it's other people
answering a question or problem that you
might have if those answers you can see
that's something that will help other
people great that should be your
guideline if you're an expert trying to
go through the forums and help other
people one of the things that's going to
be nice about our forums is that we
actually do customized emails and
digests based on your level of expertise
and so I'll explain a little bit about
that in a second you want to search
before you post therefore you're not
posting duplicate content and all that
stuff gets aggregated in a nice way
don't spam or scrape any
in start-up school it ruins our
resources but also it's a waste of your
time to do things like that and we
organized a maze these are very very
popular posts in the start school forums
on Mondays and Fridays we either ask
different experts from from the YC
alumni or we'll have panels of people to
answer questions and if you want to
launch your company to the start school
community then you stop show startup
school discussion forum or if you need
technical support help like programming
or engineering questions use the
engineering Channel but overall try to
ask the forum for help because out of
28,000 founders you guys are experts in
all the different types of categories so
we have like nine thousand engineers six
thousand people will get a product four
thousand people who have experience
doing what operations two thousand
salespeople thirteen hundred designers
and eleven hundred scientists and so as
a result there's the odds are there's
someone who has some kind of experience
some kind of hack or tool that can help
and answer your question and so in the
forums is where you should utilize that
expertise this is what those forums look
like they're super great the library so
this is pretty straightforward it's all
our written content written by YC
Partners alumni and experts we trust
they're organized by topic and stage of
the startup we have no required reading
in start-up school but I really
recommend you taking the time to go
through the articles especially when
you're stuck on one of those sort of
topic areas I always find it
enlightening every time I go back and
read old PG I say I always glean
something new out of it that I forgot
about from before and so hopefully you
will be able to use this newly or
his wisdom to your benefit we're
constantly updating with content from YC
so make sure you use it
deels Steven the batch director has
killed it for you guys he's crushed it
with gigging over 30,000 dollars worth
of deals and credits from for you
startup school companies and they are
from good companies AWS Google Microsoft
Brax stripe etc and some of the deals
actually get even better and sweeter if
you graduate from the program and again
we make it really easy for you and so if
you graduate more free stuff for you do
not share the deals with others or they
could be revoked so basically these are
for the startup school community do not
share them with others this is what that
looks like you can find it in the
sidebar all right whoa that's all the
software here are your next steps submit
your weekly update Kyle's probably
already sent you an email you got to do
it by Wednesday so that you can be part
of the group session start this week on
on the right note if the numbers are
zero if you are not launched if you
haven't talked to any users that is okay
just write that down and then recommit
yourself to make sure that that's not
what's gonna be put out for the next
week update your profile your company
and add co-founders if you need to do
that then browse through the forums the
library and the deals look through the
directories who who else is also closer
around you and see if there might be
stuff that you might want to participate
with informally or not on Thursday we're
launching our first lecture and group
sessions we're really really excited
about start at school 2019 I'm so
thankful and humbled about so many
people participating in this program and
I can't wait to show you what we've been
working on good luck and I'll see you
out there
bye